tonight a Turkish Court had sentenced
the mayor of Istanbul to nearly three
years in prison and that effectively
bans him from running again for
political office the center left ekram
imamolu is a popular opposition leader
who is seen as a major Challenger to
turkey's conservative incumbent
president Richard erdogan
the court today found him guilty of
insulting public officials he criticized
officers who annulled the results of
Istanbul's local elections back in 2019.
imamolu denies the charges he says that
he plans to appeal
our correspondent Dorian Jones in
Istanbul he told me what is behind this
sentence
well if you speak to the government they
insist that
mayor Imam Olu insulted her an official
public official and that is against the
law in Turkey he was convicted and has
been sentenced now the opposition they
totally discredit this argument saying
that this is purely political they say
that the fact that he is seen a memorial
is a potential Challenger to erdog one
in next year's presidential elections it
underscores that this is an attempt to
remove him from the political field on
top of that the words he used officials
public officials he called them fools
for overturning his initial mayoral of
victory in Istanbul in 2019 and banning
political officials through the courts
is nothing unusual and Imam all those
architect of his victory the head of the
CHP in Istanbul Jonathan Angelo she's
been banned from politics for a tweet
against President erdogan and on top of
that in 2016 the leader of the country's
second largest opposition party salatin
demitash he's been in jail under a case
which the European Court of Human Rights
was called politically motivated and
Dorian so how much power then or how
much power did Mr molu have
um vis-a-vis redship erdogan I mean how
much of a threat is he really to the
president
all you have to understand is he's a
victory in 2019 and taking control of
Istanbul was a political earthquake for
25 years erdogan's a AKP party and it's
islamist predecessor had an iron grip on
the city it was impregnable no one
thought it could ever be taken but
imamola successfully United a very
divided opposition the conservatives the
left Kurdish parties he brought them
together in a successful Coalition that
defeated erdogan's AKP and removed what
was the jewel in the crown for erdogan
the second most powerful position in
turkey and that in many ways has shaped
the opposition going forward turned it
into a powerful force that now is a
threat to erdogan and Imam all in many
ways is seen as one of the Architects
for that and that's why he's seen as
such a rival and is scoring so high in
the opinion polls and how he's appealing
his conviction and that can take two
years so he still has a possibility if
he's selected a scandal to challenge but
if the process is expedited which some
people believe there are now other
challenges the mayor of Ankara is also
seen as someone who's doing very well in
the polls the opposition really believed
they have a chance and in many ways it
all goes back to Imam always victory in
Istanbul and and the opposition will
they continue to feel that they have a
chance after what happened today I mean
is this
um this
decision is it going to have a chilling
effect
on the country at the moment
following the the verdict here in
Istanbul many of the Coalition of
opposition parties leaders came here
including Mero akshana the league of the
powerful e-party which is a key
Coalition partner of the CHP in opposing
erdogan she delivered a speech to the
large crowd saying that in the 90s
erdogan as mayor was removed from office
for reciting a poem and sent to jail
after that he went on to lead his party
to become into Paris Prime Minister and
then president she said turkey's heard
that song and that song is again playing
again the rapturous rules of Applause in
many ways they see that this could be a
springboard for uniting your position to
bring down erdog one in June elections
next year well we know you will be
following this story Dorian Jones for us
tonight with the ladies from Istanbul
Dorian thank you